et fait d'un berne attention parce que
sinon ce n'est pas en fermant le spvm
embauchera 450 nouveaux policiers mais
plus d'effectifs est la solution pas du
tout le nombre d'effectifs il n'est pas
du tout reliée au niveau de rudyard
politiquement c'est plus gagnant pour
nos élus d'avoir ce discours la ville de
vancouver à 189 policiers par cent mille
habitants à winnipeg 176 toronto 167 et
c'est à montréal que l'on retrouve déjà
plus de policiers soit 204 par cent
mille habitants et toronto à un indice
de gravité criminalité moins élevé que
celui de la métropole il se pose
question d'augmenter le total de ce
petit cd d'employer le nom de festivent
actuelle d'une manière
différente je pense qu'il faut faire un
exercice de fond en comble vraiment le
structurer quelles sont les tâches
quelles sont les fonctions qui sont
faites actuellement par exemple par des
politiques pour être faite par d'autres
personnes l'ancien membre du spvm
regrette qu'aucun plan précis pour le
déploiement des effectifs ou sa
rétention n'aient été présenté à la
population
voici ce qu'on a besoin du voici ou non
vos limites parce que actuellement mais
mais avec les escouades j'entendais bon
romaine enfants par l'incidence un
moment donné on peut créer tellement
d'escouade qu'on va refaire une escouade
pour coordonner les escouades depuis 20
ans plusieurs chercheurs se sont penchés
sur les meilleures pratiques pour
enrayer la violence urbaine sûr que je
vois au moral ce qui a personne qui est
au courant de ce tour naissance lee le
guen mort de québec investir dans les
travailleurs de proximité offrir des
services sociaux la science démontre que
leurs emportements du filet social donne
de bons résultats
toutes les annonces qui vont être faites
50% en prévention 50% système de justice
vous allez voir la différence
complètement pour l'instant 225 millions
$ seront réservés aux politiques contre
25 pour les travailleurs sociaux estime
marie josée paquet comme radio canada
montréal